[Applaudissements]
il est très léger ouais d'injures et les
membracides voilà c'est d'aller
soutiennent que montano est ce que le
quart nord est mais daniel est ce que
vous voulez ou pas besoin d'essayer ils
vont faire sans rien plus j'ai pu le
maintenant mais je ne veux pas me forcer
avec thierry moreau hier comme ça je
vais je veux non dans une halle berry
elle ne veut pas pas de pélissier on
n'est pas chez jardiland g précédera toi
dans ma vie comme c'est un beau avoir
une période longue mais j'ai
l'impression vous n'êtes pas chaude
non mais c'est impressionnant ce qu'on
voulait oui ou non chasse
oui je recommande qui jouait le vaut
bien alors alors que tu puisses pas
continue mais une musique tous faim qui
s'est alors un billet champagne âgé en
croatie pour être devant une vitrine de
pâtisserie elle va écouter
[Applaudissements]
violent
la dell qui viennent me dire un truc que
tu trouveras vinyle agnel j'adore cette
émission